encre pastel métal ou bois ici les
matériaux se rencontrent et se répondent
des créatures rouillé fantaisiste de
ghislain de l'usso aux formes sensuelles
sculpté par frédéric marquis des
personnages féminins qui se tordent et
se retourne pour occuper l'espace
c'est vraiment une histoire de
mouvements de ces lois est en mouvement
il commet une silhouette qui apparemment
est justin une une image va être modelé
et va être va prendre l'espace et va au
contraire donner une grande impression
de volume et d'espèces menacées l'espace
et le volume qui m'intéresse énormément
huit artistes réunis dans une même
exposition
leur point commun ils sont tous lauréats
des biennale de peinture et de sculpture
de voisins-le-bretonneux brigitte
whitechurch et professeur au centre
alfred de vigny elle dévoile à nouveau
son travail autour du papier c'est un
jeu avec la matière et avec les matières
du papier quand il est déjà tout froissé
ou quand il ya déjà des tâches ou voilà
quand il est texturé toute la trame de
vertical et d'horizontal tout le jeu de
ces lignes
ça me fascinait
pas mal alors j'ai fait toutes les
séries là dessus avec les papiers
le visiteur plonge dans un univers
urbain des étals colorés
une découverte de toute la richesse
artistique de notre territoire